[Music]  good sunday morning i'm bianca holman  we're going to start this morning off  with some developing news this morning  metro looking for multiple suspects  involved in a deadly shooting  one person was shot and killed near  vegas valley  drive at mountain vista just before 11  o'clock  last night police say shot spotter  activation alerted them to the scene  and when they arrived police found one  victim in a car suffering from multiple  gunshot wounds  multiple subjects were seen running from  the area shortly after the gunshots were  fired  because of that we're asking the public  to contact las vegas metropolitan police  department homicide section  or through crime stoppers metro says  they don't have a  detailed description of the suspects yet  when we get that we will keep that  posted on our mobile app and also on our  website if you  know anything about this situation call  crime stoppers you can see that number  on your screen  385-5555